would you rather have a finger for a
penis or penis for a finger I'm Jade and
these are the shocking questions hi I'm
Kim and these are my shocking answers
are you ready to go first question can
you rap a little bit of do it I've
retired this isn't gonna work if you're
not gonna work with me okay which TV
show would you most like to go on Great
British Bake Off why does he love
cooking are you gonna end I'm actually
alright - yeah I'm really good what's
your signature cake oh no i thought i
couldn't takeso i okay would you rather
have a finger for a penis or penis for a
finger I'd rather my penis be a finger
because I'll tell you why because okay
every day I don't want to look and have
one one finger that looks like a pig but
I always think that even if it was the
same finger yeah still do some acquit
yeah but fake finger if you switch
genders for the day what is the first
thing you would do if I've got have you
been to see amber in 95 what is your
sexiest feature my ears okay some people
that are there is I actually like my
ears yeah well you're entitled to love
yourself exactly Oh who would win in a
fight out of you and clay he knows that
as well he knows I've got a bit of a
dark side but during dark fighting
against the hogeol wardrobe which member
of Little Mix would do Dave
no he's enormous no no I don't think it
was she I think she she's got a
boyfriend but that if I was to know who
are you most proud to have as a follower
on social media
OMG big guy we started off with
searching a little bit name we've time
he just started not really replying and
then he gave me his number then blue
took me a few times and then I messaged
to get him you blue tip me again so now
I just message when I feel right yeah
I'm gonna pay for his birth that's it of
a really long birthday message that you
can apply to this I'm I'm so proud of
you where you've come and stuff and he
was at Cheers
and I was like I'll leave it from
charges I just go in where I need have
you read Christie's biography he
released last year did I just say that
he gave that to me as a birthday present
ah so he was my birthday he's sharing
with me or my I'm sorry that I'm late
because if they after so I'm like the
birthday present the confidence now we
both like making a bit more money you
might got me hungry you know it's awful
it could be anything
sign me he's booked oh who did you like
least on my violence least favorite
thing about Chris is my best friend you
have the power
okay come on we're gonna quickfire some
big okay when was the last time you had
sex
we have to stop I can't my mom will see
this it's a big black bible fan but I'm
acceptable will get for it I'll make try
out so the next time okay when did you
lose your virginity you can't expect me
titles alone I can't that seventeen okay
perfect
do you think you and amber could ever
get back together I'm not don't I why
cuz I'm positive okay I'm not gonna do
it I've loved my lesson one question at
the time have you ever peed in the
shower everyday do you know
one of those that I save it to gain the
shelf
who would have been the worst person
today on the island yes who is the most
stupid sighs I'm sorry these are really
really [ __ ] question said the other
ones are too naive I've got lots of
these who is hotter you will crazies ha
ha ha ha see you answered it you said
Chris is hot but you still delivered
there I love I felt upset saying it
you've let me down right last question
here you ready
I'll promise under aunt Lysa okay good
no matter what it is waver okay what is
your most embarrassing interaction with
a celebrity this is really embarrassing
I was I was really nervous if then I was
at v-- first of all I was meeting all
the eyes and Krept and Konan were
talking to me and Cohen I was hope that
was talking to it I thought he was
someone else
I went always Conan is he when I am and
I went have you changed your okay right
now about it the same for four years I
was just like that's bad that's bad bad
I know what I just I was nervous
right so we're at the end of all the
questions we done all right you gonna
try yeah I will try but there's a lot of
questions
you